over the past thirty plus years Joel and
Ethan Coen have become one of the most
prominent filmmaking duo's in the
history of cinema while it's all but
impossible to find a genuine black mark
among their work Coen Brothers movies
are not all created equal well the Coen
Brothers remake of the 1955 Brit crime
flick is often gorgeous to look at
nothing else really works and The
Ladykillers the comedy falls flat the
moral quandary czar simplistic a best
and pandering at worst Tom Hanks's
Turner's a would-be Southern gentleman
is particularly distracting now wanna
know what's going now the thirst for
knowledge is very commendable thing
there's not much to say about The
Ladykillers except that it's a rare
genuine misfire for the talented duo for
those who don't recall this occasionally
hilarious crime picture intolerable
cruelty starts George Clooney as a
divorce lawyer and Catherine zeta-jones
as a gold digger about to dupe a
billionaire oil baron sadly despite
palpable chemistry between Clooney and
Zita Jones the film misses the mark
still intolerable cruelty does feature
one of George Clooney's all-time
greatest line readings
[Music]
fascinate me
ultimately the film is bogged down by
labored plotting thinly drawn side
characters and a third act that twists
one too many times for the film to rank
among the Cohens best set on the back
lots of a film studio in the 1950s Hail
Caesar saw the Cohens making a Hollywood
fable about the studio system of old
told through the eyes of a studio fixer
the movie doubles in just about every
film genre you can imagine from crime to
fathom back again unfortunately there's
just a bit too much going on for any one
storyline to resonate that ultimately
leaves Hail Caesar
one of the brothers weaker works
although that still makes it better than
most movies I get released would the
would the twister stammers would the
twisters would the dirt worst roof of
rueful roof burn after reading features
a screenplay that somehow ranks among
both the darkest and funniest the
Cohen's of ever written
not to mention stellar performances from
George Clooney Frances McDormand
John Malkovich Tilda Swinton and a
marvelously over-the-top Brad Pitt's the
guy the guy so is he high up uh I don't
know if he's high probably to be honest
if Burn After Reading have been released
anywhere else in the Coens filmography
it would likely rank higher on this list
unfortunately the film was released a
year after No Country for Old Men and
Wellborn is occasionally brilliant it
still comes across a bit shallow in the
shadow of such lofty fare with it's hard
to love characters its dialogue that
verges on annoying its absurdist plot
and the twists of the fantastical that
never quite feels natural the hudsucker
proxy is undoubtedly one of the most
maligned and forgotten films in the
brothers filmography that's a shame
because a closer look reveals well drawn
characters a giddily ridiculous plot and
clever fast-paced dialogue chief
just first I want to apologize to what
seven
yeah I was all wet about your idea man
well thanks for being so generous in
shorts the hudsucker proxy might be the
most misunderstood and underrated films
the Cohens of made to date it took some
serious confidence to tackle a remake of
true greats a film held in high esteem
by film fans and the novices alike
the Cohens wisely didn't try to reinvent
the wheel allowing the Western narrative
to enfold him pretty much the same
fashion as the original of course they
also dressed the story up with their own
narrative and stylistic flourishes and
pulled brilliant performances from Jeff
Bridges Matt Damon and their newcomer
Hailee Steinfeld altogether they just
didn't make a great we make of a classic
film they made one of the best remakes
of all time if the hudsucker proxy is
the most misunderstood film in the
cohens body of work it's only because
the man who wasn't there is a film all
but beyond rational comprehension Billy
Bob Thornton plays a dispirited sub
verbose barber who thinks his ship has
come in when a stranger offers a chance
to invest in a new fad called dry
cleaning me I don't talk much I just cut
the hair from that unusual set up but
the brothers spin one of the weirdest
stories they've ever concocted and
deliver a wholly original neo noir
thriller fit for the modern age it's an
utterly unique film even for the
idiosyncratic filmmakers if their
staggering body of work has taught us
anything is that the Coen brothers have
no shortage of original stories to tell
for proof look no further than the
Ballad of Buster Scruggs a sprawling
western anthology film composed of six
disparate stories of the West some are
funny
others dramatic and a couple a downright
heartbreaking in true Coen fashion those
elements are often at play within the
same story making the Ballad of Buster
Scruggs a giddy and galvanizing
cinematic experience even if it isn't
quite coherent enough to rank among
their very best we all love hearing
about ourselves so long as the people in
the stories are us but not us not us in
the end especially set in a bustling
prohibition-era metropolis Miller's
Crossing follows the chief adviser of a
mob kingpin as they try to navigate the
shifting tides but particularly nasty
turf
of those tides will say that they never
lead quite where you'd expect that the
stakes are high and that's saying any
more would spoil the fun of watching the
film what we can say is that the Cohens
produced writing credits Miller's
Crossing and the Nile bleah stands are
some of their finest to work
it's a harrowing mistaken identity crime
thriller about an average dude trying to
replace a shrug it's a campy comedy
classic about the fish out of water who
gets in way over his head in the seedy
on the ground of the San Fernando Valley
it's a character study about an aging
stoner whose ambition in life is to
smoke drink white Russians and
occasionally hit the bowling alley for
league play it's also one of the
greatest cult films ever made and one of
the most quotable scripts ever produced
look there's really not that much we can
say about the Big Lebowski that hasn't
been said already
you either abide The Big Lebowski as the
masterfully envisioned the madcap stoner
epic masterpiece that it is or well
you're just wrong like crime and
criminals religion has often found its
way into the Coens films in their
caustic farce a serious man the brothers
deliver a complicated religious parable
about a Jewish psychics professor
searching for meaning as as life falls
apart around them watching a man's
entire life crumble Halle sounds like
the formula for great comedy but even in
the film's heaviest moments the Cohens
add just enough levity to keep it from
becoming a blunt-trauma sort of drama if
you grew up in the Jewish faith the film
with its winking in jokes and scores of
Judaic details will hit extremely close
to home
oh brother where art thou is a
depression-era tale about penniless
escaped convicts perilously traversing
the American South in search of a fabled
treasure
the Cohens claim Homer's epic poem The
Odyssey as a film source material though
they also claim to have never read the
poem itself thus okay because the
buttery beautiful alternate musical they
crafted is a timeless hilarious Southern
Fried epic in its own right it finally
brought the Cohens off-kilter
sensibilities to the mainstream and it's
bluegrass II soundtrack became a legit
cultural phenomenon a tragic tale of a
kidnapping scheme gone unimaginably
wrong against the icy backdrops of North
Dakota and men
soda Fargo features everything you could
possibly want from a Coen Brothers film
and don't argue with us I'm not I'm not
arguing here I'm cooperating and there's
no we're doing all we can
well fargo is one of the Coens more
serious cinematic ventures it still
features that signature dark humor
vibrant language colorful characters and
of course brutal outbursts of violence
it all comes together to make Fargo one
of the most uniquely Coen Eska movies
ever made set against the barren dusty
vistas of a desolate desert town
Raising Arizona tells the story of a
couple who in the face of fertility
troubles decide to kidnap a baby Raising
Arizona only gets crazier as that
improbable narrative unfolds which maybe
raises a few questions
it's raising Arizona a comedy of errors
about lovable kidnappers yes is it a
reagan-era parable about trickle-down
economics and the prison reform gone
haywire seems like it is raising Arizona
a radically idealistic faster higher
ordered the arrival of a bold new
cinematic vision 100% it's crazy in all
the best ways and if you don't believe
that you simply cannot call yourself a
Coen Brothers fan as the story goes
while the brothers were writing Miller's
Crossing they hit a creative wall so
fierce they put the project on hold in
hopes of kick-starting their creative
juices they conceptualized a new film
centered around a character created
specifically for John Turturro from the
creative void of writer's block barton
fink a while the original scathingly
satirical pseudo mystical masterpiece
was born a masterpiece about of all
things a writer facing a devastating
creative block not to mention a
full-fledged metaphysical crisis of
identity that may or may not directly
involve the devil simply puts Barton
Fink as a haunting look at the life of
the creative mind the likes of which
moviegoers had never seen before and the
possibly even since Lewin Davis is
manipulative and self-centered but he's
also an intensely likable guy who
usually tries to do the right thing but
messy texture is what makes inside
Llewyn Davis such a fascinating
experiment in character I have the money
don't worry with you I worry well you
shouldn't
yes I
God knows you never do it helps with the
carrot simmers played with equal parts
charm swagger and crippling insecurities
by Oscar Isaac in a star-making turn
watching Isaac portrays such an
identifiable beautifully flawed
character is enough to make inside
Llewyn Davis worth a look that the music
the settings and the supporting
characters are crafted with equal skill
and care and that's what makes inside
Llewyn Davis one of the Cohen's most
memorable works to date while it's hard
to believe that the Cohens made their
feature debut over 30 years ago
it's hard as still to believe just how
much they got right with our debut film
make no mistake a Blood Simple is still
every bit the biting brutal exacting ly
scripted and exquisitely photographed
noir soap thriller it was upon its
release its menacing white-knuckle
finale will leave your palm sweaty as it
unfolds before your eyes blood simple as
one of the most staggeringly assured
debut films ever produced
and it remains one of the Coen brothers
best period written by legendary scribe
Cormac McCarthy and possessed of stark
Western themes embracing weds no country
for old men seemed tailor-made for the
Cohens peculiar sensibilities
sensibilities aside the Cohens took the
bones of McCarthy's novel and ran with
them delivering a high-minded art film
dressed up as one of the greatest crime
chase trailers cinema has ever seen
along the way they poured startingly
sparse performances from Tommy Lee Jones
and Josh Brolin and an iconic Lee
villainous turn from Javier Bardem
in short no country stands as the
crowning achievement of Joel and Ethan
Coen career in film is something wrong
the world with anything yesterday what
you're asking me is there something
wrong with anything check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]